[Music]
all the species of kong are highly
civilized and technological oddity
amongst titans
well in this video we shall dive deep
into the hollow earth and also skull
island to reveal the hidden truth of
this
titan species the most human of them all
the most intelligent of them all and if
you haven't seen godzilla vs kong then
spoilers ahead
and if you have seen it then enjoy don't
say i didn't warn you
but before you do remember to click that
subscribe button to be a part of the
mind cure family
and also hit that notification bell for
regular updates
anyway in this video we will look into
their very nature
and the fact that they built tools and
even a kingdom for themselves
so let's get down with this sickness
let's start with their description the
most diverse incarnation of governments
mostly based on the 1933 incarnation of
him standing upright
like a human with his incredible long
arms held
at his sides and he stood 104 feet in
the first appearance
kong's first light brown color and
covers the majority of his body except
for his face
chest and hands and also feet kong's
skin is dark grey in colour and he has
large scars running across his chest
kong has small rounded ears
on the sides of his head and possesses
many ape-like features on his face such
as a flat nose
with rounded nostrils and large canine
teeth in his mouth
that was the 1973 and olsen gong the
adult kong
is 356 feet tall has a beard on his chin
and although he walks upright he travels
faster on all fours like a gorilla
the species of kong most probably
started evolving millions of years after
the other tyrants like methuselah and
godzilla
the species if taken from the standpoint
of known evolutionary biology
would have probably taken off quite
recently as compared to the others
as apes especially gorillas they started
evolving around 10 million years ago
it would be fair to presume that one of
these species somehow found their way
into the hollow earth and then began to
take in the unique radiation from the
power source
and then became the titan species of
present time at least in the monster
verse
and as these super species began growing
they had to survive
and fight existing threats and along the
way develop rivalries with the likes of
skrull crawlers gojiras
warbats and camazotz these titan species
of gongs were probably newbies in the
hollow earth
and in order to survive as they grew and
evolved they would have had to use the
one thing that is very
important and the main evolutionary
advantage of them
their intellect they would later form
communities and which became powerful as
they become bigger
and the community became a kingdom and
this became a threat to the one alpha
species
titanus gojira although it is not
explained specifically
the two species waged war against each
other for a long time
which ended in both of them dwindling in
numbers as
8-kill lizard and lizard killed ape the
kongs probably had a numerical advantage
and the crafting of weapons such as the
present battle axe
made from a dorsal plate of a gojira and
a muted bone handle
this rivalry would have ended in gojiras
retreating to the oceans and kongs to
skull island like a truce
the kongs before their exile towards the
surface would have been a very advanced
species with the use of primal
technology
very different from humans but evolving
in perilous fashion
although they were not using iphones or
spacex dragon capsules
they were smart enough to harness the
radioactive energy from the core
from the limitless power source for
constructing monuments
weapons and tools that would be used for
their very survival and expansion
during godzilla vs calm as they went
inside the hollow earth
they discovered kong species ancestral
throne room that depicts an ancient war
with godzilla's kind
they also find a glowing axe made from
the dorsal plates of another godzilla
and as they find the power souls comb
discovers that it can also recharge the
balance
inside the throne room of the kongs
there were various mega structures and
even before reaching the mountain place
which was their seat of power there was
another structure built by the kongs to
safely transition from one side of the
hollow earth to another without having
to deal much with the gravity inversion
so outside there was a huge hand that
even dwarfed the size of kong
i think this would have been made by
them as a hand resembling an ape hand
they can easily let other kongs know
where to cross over
kong easily recognized it as such and
jumped without hesitation to reach
to the other side this would mean that
the kongs were also gifted with
craftsmanship
and stone sculpturing more like rock
carving at their gigantic scale
they even had a door with a palm print
to indicate where to push
open like a push and pull sign we see on
7-elevens
inside the throne room there were lots
of megaliths that glow blue
with the radiant energy given out from
the power souls in the middle was a
gigantic throne and as such
there should have been a king that ruled
over the other kongs
on the sides there were gigantic pillars
that held up the place and gave
out an imperial aura about it there was
even a room for gathering which means
that they also had some sort of language
that they would communicate with this is
evident with gong
understanding sign language the one used
by the eerie natives of skull island
and that he could even respond in
likeness the throne room also had a very
large statue of an ancient kong
and this shows that they were indeed
rock sculptors as well
regarding the tools and the technology
they utilized
it would be strangely alien as well as
familiar to humans
they would use stone tools and maybe
even bones from other titans to design
and build the entire throne room they
also utilized the energy source to power
their tools
much like us humans using electricity
the same way
theirs would have been a more of a stone
age civilization mixed with nuclear
energy
and they were smart enough to use it
like fire
with this they would be kings of the
hollow earth
in the same sense as humans discovering
fire and using it to become the dominant
species on the surface of the planet
even using fire against wild animals and
predators
just just like that the kongs would also
use the power source against
other more powerful titans like godzilla
but this also became their undoing as
they started a war against the apex
godzilla species
which ended up in the remaining
population of kongs
having to leave the hollow earth to live
in skull island
in this island however lacking the power
souls and the food source
they eventually began to become smaller
in size and weaker
in power against the skull crawlers and
other threats
this would have led to the skull
crawlers in their huge numbers to slowly
and steadily prey on the gong species
and in the end leaving out the last soul
survivor our calm
of course this ended in the events of
gong's skull island with him killing the
big one
and eventually eradicating the smaller
ones that came out for hunting
during the events of king of the
monsters when ghidorah started his alpha
call
in godzilla vs kong however the island
became unstable
and the storm began to envelop the
entire landscape as well as the
adjoining areas
the adjoining seas killing off the fauna
of the place and gong being rescued and
put in a containment facility
and during their later traveling into
the hollow earth kong would eventually
find out
his ancestry and forgotten past and lead
him to conflict with godzilla
but in the end kong would again return
to the hollow earth and rule over his
ancient home
while monarch establishing an
observation outpost to monitor
the last titanium scorm that's all about
gong and his species the first and the
only technological titan super species
so yes again subscribe if you haven't
and like for support as well as smash
that notification bell for regular
updates
on monsters guide you videos creature
features
godzilla vs scoring dissection videos
and much more
right here on mind cue be safe and take
care fam
you